hi I'm Brandon cope i graduated from the
master of science in public policy and
management program in 2008 and i
currently work in the Department of
Education and children's services I work
in corporate strategy and my role is
essentially about embedding
evidence-based management into all the
programs and projects that we run index
it's a little difficult to put into
words but I think it's that can-do
attitude that the Carnegie Mellon
experience gives you there's very much a
flavor of contributing to the greater
good of the altruism that's behind the
University which is something that I
haven't experienced being previously in
in other undergraduate studies but it's
that you can make a difference and I
think that that that attitude infuses
all aspects of the program the sense of
the way of the professors and lecturers
commit to students talk about real life
situations where they've made a
difference working in programs or
strategies or organizations I think
that's probably one of the the real
standout things that I didn't expect
that I absolutely got out of the program
that the program gives you the most
extraordinary confidence in being able
to work in real life situations to be
able to apply quantitative methods and
unskilled in any public policy situation
in a government or non-government
organization I think so having the
confidence to undertake essentially
consultative work with organizations is
one very powerful reason you have a
fantastic opportunity to work with with
teams of people on on real-life projects
and rather than being focused around
academic study it's it's around really
applied contexts and problem-solving on
the ground with with a group of people
so that that teamwork is is really
important
it's a it's a really nice space to work
in the classroom space is a light and
area they're well equipped with audio
visuals we've got just absolutely
state-of-the-art in terms of video
technology and so on but also the
library spaces and the study spaces I
used to study here quite quite regularly
even though in fact I work only closely
close to the campus so I really didn't
need to do that but the ability to mix
with students and meet academic staff is
just it's a very accessible I'd call it
an intimate experience it's not like
some great sprawling impersonal campus
it's very it's very much like a large
family in that sentence